fear and uncertainty ahead of the
swearing-in ceremony of gabon's Junta
leader Paris oligi and guemma opinions
are divided for some he is a break from
the past
it's a new era for Gabon after all that
we have suffered it's a new beginning
and we are taking the right step it
won't be easy for oligi but we have to
support him
others point out that oligi is a cousin
of the deposed president Ali Bongo whose
family ruled the country for 55 years
they see him as a continuation of the
regime a bongo in uniform replacing a
bongo in a suit
I don't think the military is fit to
manage a country because to manage a
country you need a social project in my
opinion they have to redo the elections
we have to have a president that the
gabonese people have chosen
breaking his assignments is gabonza
opposition Coalition candidate from
August presidential election
says he won the vote and is the
legitimate representative of the people
not the Junta
I'm a Democrat and a Democrat doesn't
accept the coup d'etat either you're a
Democrat or you're a poochist and from
that moment on I asked the military to
return to Republican order
the Junta says the vote was marred with
fraud and lacks credibility oligi
promises to bring democracy to his
country
a promise made to the people of Gabon
before but never fulfilled
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera